ๆอ้าอ่า
สวัสดีค่ะพี่สวัสดีครับน้องเรียมสวัสดี
ครับนักเรียนเย้นักเรียนเอามาเจอกับพี่
อาร์ตี้นะครับกลับมาเจอกับน้องเรียมอยู่
ตรงไหนนักเรียนอยู่ด้านไหนยกมือหน่อยมอง
ไม่เห็นให้อยู่นะท่านนี่
ในท้องอะไรครับ
ค่ายที่อ้างนี้ข้างนี้ในช่องคอมพรีเฮนโซล
ไทยนะครับ
ใช่ครับวันนี้เรามาเจอกันวันที่
วันอะไรครับวันนี้
วันนี้วันๆวันนี้วันพุธใช่ไหมครับวันนี้
วันพุธวันพุธวันพุธที่เท่าไหร่ครับวันนี้
ที่
26  5 วันพุธที่ 26 เดือนอะไรครับเดือน
นี้เดือนนี้เดือนมกราคมเดือนนี้เดือน
มกราคม
อ่าโอเค
เดือนป่ะกะราคมปีคศอะไรครับ
คศ
2005  12
2022 นะครับแล้วปีพศอะไรครับ
พ.ศ
2565 ใช้ครับ
ว้าวนะครับ 2560  5 ปีนี้ปีคศ 2000  22
ใช่ไหมครับปีนี้ใช่ค่ะพัน 22 แล้วปีที่
แล้วหล่ะครับ
ปีที่แล้วปีอะไรครับ
ปีที่แล้วปี
2021  5 ปีที่แล้วปี 2021 แล้วอ่าปีหน้า
นะครับปีหน้าปีที่เท่าไหร่ครับปีหน้าปี
2010  23
และ 3 แนวเองแล้วมีอีก 3 ปีข้างหน้านะ
ครับปีอะไรครับ
อันนี้ตามหน้า
หน้าหน้า
323 ปีอะไรครับ 3 ปีข้างหน้า
2025 อ่าปีหน้าปี 2010  20
53 ปีข้างหน้าไม่ใช่ปีหน้าอ่ะ 3 ปีข้าง
หน้า 1  2  3  3 ปีข้างหน้า 2,000
25k โอเคค่ะค่ะหน้าแล้ววันนี้ครับวันนี้
เรามาเรียนกันนี้ตอนนี้เนี่ยกี่โมงแล้ว
ครับตอนนี้
ตอนนี้
16:00 น 4 โมงใช่ไหมหนอ 16:30 น 4 โมง
อ่าครึ่งอ่ะเป็นตอนเช้า
หรือตอนเย็นครับตอนเย็นค่ะตอนเย็นใช่ไหม
โอเควันนี้ 4 โมงครึ่งตอนเย็น
โอเคครับวันนี้เรามาเรียนเรื่องอะไรกันดี
วันหน้ามีอะไรจะมาเรียนกันกับนักเรียนมี
เกมอ่ะอ่าใช่ครับ
เกมมีเกมมาให้เล่นครับ
5  ok โอยั๊แล้วยังครับ
อ้ามีแกมนะครับมีเกมส์มาให้เล่นกันนะครับ
วันนี้โอเคอ่าเกมหาหาหาหาของในภาพเดี๋ยว
พี่เปิดรูปภาพให้ดูก่อนนะอ้าเปิดรูปภาพ
ให้ดูบัตรอ้านี่ครับนี่นี่เป็นรูปภาพน้อง
เรียมเห็นแต่ในรูปมีมั้ง
เรียงเห็นหมาหน้ามีหมามีหมานั่งอยู่ตรง
นี้นะหมาทำอะไรได้แล้วนี่หมามาแลบลิ้นแลบ
ลิ้นออกมาแล้วลิ้นออกมายาวเลยนะนะนะหมา
แล้วสวัสดีค่ะ / มีกระดิกหางด้วยนี่ครับ
ก็ดิหางกระดิกหางไปกระดิกหางมานี้ใช่ไหม
กระดิดหาร 5 อ่าโอเคมาก็ดิหายด้วยอ่ะเกม
นี้เกมนี้ให้นักเรียนนะครับนักเรียนแล้ว
ก็น้องเรียมช่วยกันช่วยกันหาหาหาอะไรครับ
มีหาอันนี้
หาสิ่งนี้เอาอันนี้เรียกอะไรครับ
ไหมพรมไหมพรมมาไหมพรมเป็นก้อนกลมๆแบบนี้
ใช่ไหมอ่ะหาว่าคุณอยู่ที่ไหนอยู่ที่ไหนใน
รูปนี่หน้ามีไหมพรมอยู่ตรงไหนครับในรูปมี
ไหมพรมได้ครับถ้าน้องเรียมหาหาเจอแล้วบอก
บอกอยากปีณวัดอยู่อยู่ที่ไหน
นักเรียนมองเห็นไหมพรมไหมเห็นไหมพรมครับ
ไหมพรมกลมกลมๆแบบนี้กลมกลมๆๆกลมๆมีหา
หน่อยดิอยู่ตรงไหนครับ
เรียบคิดว่าเรียงหินอ่ะน้องเรียนใหม่รม
เจอแล้วหรอครับน้องเรียนเจอนั่นเจอไหมพรม
แล้วใช่ไหมครับขออ่ะไหมพร้อมอยู่อยู่ๆที่
ไหนครับอยู่ที่ไหนครับพี่อยู่ในอาอยู่ไหน
ในถังขยะอะเพียงดีเห็นเห็นถังขยะเดี๋ยว
นี่ทางขยะ 5 ไหมพรมอยู่ในถังขยะใช่ไหมๆ
อ๋ออยู่นี่ไงพี่เจอแล้วนี่ไหมพรมใช่ไหม
อ่าหน้าไหมพรมอยู่ตรงนี้เองอ่านี่ไหมพรม
โอเคไหมพรมเปลี่ยนสี
ใช้ครับเปลี่ยนสีนะครับไหมพรมเปลี่ยนสี
ค่ะนิเป็นสีแดงแต่ว่าอีแดงไหมพรมเป็นสี
เหลืองแล้วนะครับ 555 แต่ไหมพรมอยู่นี่
เก่งมากครับอ้าน้องเรียมหาเจอแล้วนะครับ
อ่ะหา
เจอไหมพรมอยู่ในใน
เอาถังขยะ
โอเคครับต่อไปอ่ะเดี๋ยวเราไปหาหาหาหา
ต่อครับนี่มาแล้วครับอันนี้เป็นอะไรครับ
ไส้กรอกใช่ไหมไส้กรอกใส่ครับรอเซอร์เป็น
ไส้กรอกอยู่ตรงไหนครับหามาช่วยกันช่วยกัน
หาไส้กรอกนะครับ
ไส้กรอกอยู่ตรงไหนครับ
กินห้าใช่ครับได้กินได้เป็นไส้กรอกบนโซฟา
มีไส้กรอกไหม
ไม่มีไม่หาไม่มีอะมีไส้กรอกอยู่ตรงไหน
ครับอ่ะช่วยกันหาครับ
หน้าน้องเรียมหาเจอไหมตรงนี้อ่าบนหนังสือ
หรือไม่มี
อยู่บนพื้นตรงนี้ไม่มีเออตรงนี้มีอีเอ
อยู่ตรงไหนครับ
อยู่ที่เปลือกกล้วยเปลือกกล้วยเปลือก
กล้วยเพชรที่เห็นเปลือกกล้วยอ้อเปลือก
กล้วยอยู่บนพื้นตรงนี้นะมีเปลือกกล้วย
อยู่บนพื้นตรงนี้อ่านแล้วไส้กรอกอยู่ตรง
ไหนครับ
ไม่กรอก
เรียบมองเห็นให้ปลอกหาอ๋ออ๋อเพี้ยนแล้ว
นี้ไส้กรอกสีเหลืองอยู่นี่ใช่ไหมครับนี่
นี่เท้าหาหนูยังเก่งจังเลยเจอไส้กรอกแล้ว
เย้ไส้กรอกดอกเบื่อเปลี่ยนสี
เปลี่ยนสีอีกแล้วอ่ะ
เปลี่ยนจากสีแดงแปลมีสีเหลืองจ๊ะใช่ค่ะ
โอเคอ่าไม่เป็นไรต่อไปต่อไปไหนเรามาหาอีก
นะครับอะไรคะอันนี้ครับมีหนี้อะไรครับ
หวีหวีโอเคๆนักเรียนนักเรียนช่วยกันหา
ช่วยกันหาหวีหน่อยครับหวีอยู่ไหนครับ
ง่ายมากๆขอนักเรียนเจอแล้วเหรอครับหวี
อยู่ตรงไหนอยู่เตรียมทรงเหลือนักเรียนนัก
เรียนเห็นหานักเรียนก็เห็นแล้วใช่ไหมอ้าว
อีอยู่ตรงไหนครับบนโซฟาไม่มีบนพื้นไม่มี
อยู่ในถังขยะไหมไม่มีอยู่ไหนครับอยู่บน
บนกระดาษบนกระดาษนะเพื่อที่เห็นกระดาษ
กระดาษอ้อนี่ไงมีว่าไงมีหวีอยู่บนกระดาษ 5
อยู่ตรงนี้อย่าเข้
อยู่ใกล้ๆไปๆใกล้หาอ๋อนี่ไงหา
หางหมาหนามีหวีอยู่ตรงนี้ใกล้ๆกับหางหมา
ให้ใช่ค่ะเคเย้เจออีกแล้วนะครับเขาไป
วิ่งไม่ไม่เปลี่ยนสีอ๋ออ๋อใช่ครับหวีสีสี
เดิมหน้าสีดำมาไม่เปลี่ยนสี
เคครับต่อไปนะต่อไปเรามาหาหา
อะไรคะ
หน้านี้เป็นผีเสื้อครับ
เสื้อเสื้อใช้ครับมีผีเสื้ออยู่ตรงนี้
นะครับ 5 ในรูปนี้มีผีเสื้ออยู่ตรงไหนใน
รูปนี้ครับ
น้าเลือกหายชมพู
ผีเสื้อสีชมพู
ซอฟาก็สีชมพู
ลิ้นหมาก็สีชมพูแล้วแล้วผีเสื้ออยู่ตรง
ไหนครับ
อ้าเรียกไหนว่านักเรียนเห็นอ่านักเรียน
เห็นแล้วล่ะครับหากเทียบตี้เฮียตีก็เห็น
แล้วเหมือนกันเยอะตีก็เห็นแล้วนี่
ใช่ตรงนี้ไหมนี่เหมือนเลยนี่นี่ครับอยู่
ตรงนี้
อาอยู่ที่ไหนครับ
อยู่บนบนอยู่บนดอกไม้ใช่ไหมอ่ะอยู่บนดอก
ไม้หน้ามีผีเสื้ออยู่บนดอกไม้ตรงนี้โอเค
ว้าวอ้าเราหาอะไรกันมีใบไม้ใช่ครับอยู่บน
ใบไม้อีกทีนี่ใบไม้อันนี้ดอกไม้อันนี้
ผีเสื้อ k  k หน้าไปครับ
เย้เอ้าหาเจอผีเสื้อ
เจอหวี
เจอ
ใช้ไม่พอ
เจอไหมพรม
ใช่ค่ะโอเคออกไปต่อไปเราไปหา
นี่ครับหน้าหมายเลข 5 หมายเลข 5 นี้เป็น
อะไรครับดูแล้ว
ต่อคอใช่เพียงตี้คิดว่าเป็นปลอกคอจะเป็น
ปลอกคออันเล็ก
น่าจะเป็นปลอกคอของไม่ใช่ไม่น่าจะใช่ของ
มาอาจจะเป็นปลอกคอของแมวนี่ไหมแมวใส่ปลอก
คออันเฮ้ย
เฮ้ยแฮอายุตรงไหนครับปลอกคออยู่ตรงไหน
ครับ
พี่แมวมีไหมไม่มีแมวอยู่ในกล่องมองไม่
เห็นเนอะ
[เพลง]
น่าดูสิอยู่ตรงไหนอยู่บนพื้นไม่มี
หน้าในกล่องไม่มี
มองบนกระดาษ
ไม่มี
บนโซฟา
อ่าอ่อนแต่เพียงตีเจอแล้วเรียนที่เจอแล้ว
เจอแล้ว
เจอ 5 ณเวียงเทิงหรือยังเจอรึยังค่ะครบ
เตรียมเจอแล้วเลยแล้วเหมือนว่ายังไงครับ
นี่นี้อยู่ตรงนี้ครับอยู่ที่ไหนครับ
อยู่บนหออยู่บนถาวรรองเท้าอ่านี่ครับมี
ลอกข้อข้ออยู่บนรองเท้าตรงนี้นะครับเออ
ว้าว
ยีเย่เย้ต่อไปคลอหน้ามีปลอกคอปกคอของแมว
นะหาเจอแล้วอยู่นี่นี่เอง
เหอะเราหาข้าวหาเจอแล้วถ้าอย่างได้เราหา
เจอแล้วห้าอย่างห้าอย่างนะมาต่อไปเราไปหา
หาอย่างที่ 6 กันโภคาอย่างที่ 6  5 อะไร
ครับนี่คืออะไรครับอย่างที่ 6 ถ้วยห้า
เป็นถ้วยใช่ไหมครับโอเคอ้าเรามาช่วยกันหา
มีกล้วยนะครับว่าอยู่ด้วยอยู่ตรงไหนครับ
มีไหมเห็นในถังขยะมีไหมไม่มีบนพื้นไม่มี
ไม่มีในกล่องไม่มีไม่มีบนกระดาษ
ไม่มีอ้าน้องเรียนเจอหรือยังครับอยู่ตรง
ไหนครับเตรียม
ตื่นแล้วก็เจอแล้วหรอครับอยู่ไหนครับ
อยู่บนอยู่บนอีกแล้วอายุบนบนอะไรครับบน
โซฟาอ๋ออ๋อบนโซลไฟล์เลยนะพี่ติ
นิยายหน่อยไม่ใช่ให้หายขอเออแล้วนี่พี่
ขยายเจอแล้วโอ้นี่นะป้าขยายออกมาเจอถ้วย
เนี่ยถ้วย hey  hey  hey  hey
กล้วยนิถ้วยอยู่บนโซฟาผ้า K
ถ้วยแล้วหา
หาเจอแล้ว 6 อย่างใช่ครับหาเจอแล้ว 6
อย่างหน้าเดี๋ยวเราไปหาไปหาชิ้นต่อไปต่อ
ไปอย่างที่ 7 ใช่ไหมครับใช่ 5 อย่างที่
เจ็บหา
อะไรคะพี่ฮับ
มาหา
เจ๊อันนี้คือลูกเทนนิสใช่ไหมครับรูป
เทนนิส 5 รูปเงินนิสค.ลูกเทนนิสกลมกลมๆลม
กลมๆอยู่ตรงไหนครับมีตรงไหนมีลูกเทนนิสลม
กลมๆบ้างอ่ะตรงนี้ใช่ไม่ใช่
ไม่ใช่มีไหมกลมอันนี้ไม่ใช่
เตรียมคิดว่า
ลูกชนิดเปลี่ยนสีรอบเปลี่ยนสีนะครับ
เปลี่ยนเป็นสีสีอะไรครับน้องเรียมเห็น
แล้วเห็นแล้วใช่ไหมนักเรียนเจอแล้วใช่ไหม
ครับขอเปรียบเจอแล้วเจอแล้วว้าวอยู่ตรง
ไหนครับ
อยู่ใกล้ๆแมวไม่ๆแม้ว่าเบียร์ตี้เห็นแมว 5
ประเภทที่หาลูกเทนนิสกลมๆนี้ไม่ใช่อ้อย
อันนี้ไม่ครับ
นี่ใช่ค่ะพี่ปาร์ตี้เจอแล้วกลมๆมีมีมีมี
มีโอเอ็ดดี้ดูแล้วพี่ติ๊กคิดคิดว่าโอ้นี่
เป็นแอปเปิ้ล
ให้ค่ะเฮ็ดดีคิดว่าเป็น Apple น่ะแต่ว่า
มันมีหามีเส้นแล้วก็เป็นกลมเหมือนลูก
เทนนิสใช่ไหมใช่ค่ะลูกเทนนิสเปลี่ยน
เปลี่ยนสีแดงรอบเหลี่ยนเป็นสีแดงโอเค
แต่น้องเรียมก็ขาดเจอเดี๋ยวหาเจอนะฮะโอเค
เธอต่อไปอ่าเดี๋ยวเราไปนะครับหาหา
อย่างที่ 8 โอเค
อย่างที่ 8 นี้อะไรครับ
อะไรคะอ๋อ
บ้านบ้านเดี๋ยวโอเคค่ะมีบ้านบ้านแล้วโอเค
บ้านอยู่ตรงไหนครับพี่
หมู่บ้านอยู่ตรงไหนในถังขยะมีไหม
บ้านในถังขยะอย่างอยู่ตรงไหนไปกิจว่า
[เพลง]
ไม่มีในถังขยะบนพื้นบนพื้นมีไหมคนคืนไม่
มีไม่มีใช่ไหม
หน้าที่ต้นไม้ก็ไม่มีไม่มี 5 บนหนังสือ
ไม่มี
หน้าบนโซฟามีไหมครับ
ไม่มีค่ะไม่มีเลขอยู่ไหนอ่ะอ่ะเฮียตี้เจอ
แล้วพี่คิดว่าเบี้ยตี้เจอแล้วครับนัก
เรียนนักเรียนเจอหรือยังครับเจอรึยัง
เย้
ยายขึ้นมาหัวหน้าตอนนี้เรียกที่คิดว่านัก
เรียนเจอแล้วใช่มั้ยน้องเรียมก็เจอแล้ว
ใช่ไหมครับน่าอยู่ที่ไหนครับบ้านอยู่ที่
ไหนครับใกล้ๆหนาวหอมใกล้ๆแมวนับอยู่ข้าง
กล่องตรงนี้นี่เองนะครับน่าอยู่ข้างกล่อง
ตรงนี้อ่าอันนี้มีบ้านอยู่ว้าวมาเย่ครับ
หน้ามีอะไรอีกครับอันนี้อย่างที่ 8 แล้ว
ใช่ไหมเรายังมีอีกครับอ่ามาช่วยกันหาต่อ
ครับช่วยกันหา
อะไรคะนี่ครับอันนี้
เรียก
กระดูก
มันดูใช่ครับ
หากกระดูกอยู่ตรงไหนก็ดูที่หมาตัวนี้หมา
ตัวนี้ชอบชอบกินกระดูกน่ะแล้วค่อยดูอาอิ
อีอุตตระดู่แล้วก็ดูกอยู่ตรงไหนครับ
มีแม็กซ์เรียน
เรียนหาเจอไหมครับ
เจอมั้ยฮะหายเพื่อดูดเจอไหมเนี่ยพี่
อาร์ตี้ขีดไม่เจอพี่ก็ขี่อ้าวเบียร์ตี้
คิดว่าเบียร์ตีเห็นแอลเฮียตี้เห็นแล้ว
กระดูกมานักเรียนก็เห็นแล้วใช่ไหมครับอ้า
นี้เบื่อเหมือนกันเลยนี่ก็ดูก็ดูก็ดูอยู่
ที่ไหนครับ
อยู่ที่หมอนหน้าอยู่ข้างบ่อนใช่ไหมกระดูก
อยู่ข้างหมอนตรงนี้ข้างหมอนใช่ครับ
โอเคอ้าวันนี้เราหาเจอหลายอย่างเลยเราหา
อะไรเจอบ้างครับวันนี้ฮ่าๆไหม
หัว
หน้าหาใหม่พร้อมนี้
เราก็เมียอีกครับให้กรอกให้กรอก 5
มีอะไรอีกครับผีเสื้อใช่ไหมหน้าแล้วก็
หวีครับ 5 มีรอคอ
เหล้าคอลัมนิสต์มีลูกเทนนีส
มีบ้านนะครับอ่ามีถ้วยไม่อันก็มีกระดู
ว้าวโอเคแล้วก็นี่ก็คือทั้งหมดที่เราหา
เจอกันในวันนี้อ่ะทุกคนเก่งมากๆนักเรียน
เก่งมากน้องเรียมเก่งมากครับน้าขอบคุณค่ะ
โอเควันนี้เราหมดเวลาอีกแล้วอ่ะเราเล่น
เกมกันหมดเวลาแล้วครับเดี๋ยวหัวหน้ากลับ
มาเรียนภาษาไทยกลับมาเล่นเกมกับเพียบอี้
กับพี่น้องเรียมในช่องคอมพลีเมนโซโลไทย
กันใหม่นะครับใช่แล้วคนนี้น้องเรียมกับ
เตี้ยปี้ต้องลาไปก่อนครับทุกคนค่าบ๊ายบาย
สวัสดีครับนักเรียนที่สวัสดีครับน้อง
เรียมสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนม